it's Friday that means mic please the
people and we already have a challenge
coming in remember rated chat so right
here we go I'm gonna accept okay Google
alright well viewers like most Fridays
Mike comer is here to play against
everybody please join us on Leech s and
challenges joking around or join us on
chess calm okay what is that really are
we playing chess calm oh never mind
chess calm why are we still playing at
rest at home Danny
alright Danny's choice oh we're gonna go
ahead and speaking of which let's go
ahead and give us a give a shout-out to
our man in the back Danny Machuca so my
mistake challenges on chess calm and
then we will accept your challenge in a
week Thomas of course the home of the
pro chest League now it many people
probably don't know they have a new
format for 2020 there is absolutely no
rating cap it used to be a rating cap of
nine nine nine nine point seven five so
basically for 2500 you know but now
there is no rating cap so guess who we
have on our team any you want to guess
you want to make a guess I kind of
already know majority of them all right
so we have Fabiano Wesley so one year
Dominguez and week one will so you have
like four there's no world on your teeth
yes that's okay and just work just to
balance it out we still have Nicolas
Rosenthal and Josh bloomer yeah you know
you know some some wheat weaker players
all right Gary bliss time control please
5-0 or under five zero and we're
solitare radio games only because we
will absolutely decline non-reader games
absolutely yeah no no participation
prizes here now you either win or you
lose
whether you lose win points lose points
Waco is Danny gonna make no he's no I
thought they was gonna make an
appearance on camera for everybody but
he but he didn't he's chose to walk
behind the camera it's not about it's
not about making appearance before it's
about making a parents now hey I got I
got a bag of jerky for you right now
stay behind me behind me all right I
guess I'm gonna bust out the cash here
we go big bank big banks beats little
bank big big I know because I I um I
don't carry $100 bills around for no
reason like why would I why would you
carry why would you have to so 2019
almost 2020 we're carrying cash around
$100 bills who does that who does that
this is me you you're inviting me to
like punch you out and take them off
with money from you that's what's
happening right now
the $300 man gets a free quiz you are
though you're one nada maybe you're
probably the only one I know it goes 200
even though no reason like why why I
mean I could I could be like here's my
ATM card that's nothing that's that
gonna cover it so last night I got to go
to a live taping of the prices right it
was in uh st. Charles Todd Newton was
the host he did a great job and there
was a lot of fun I was there just
yelling I did so good with the UH with
you know the pricing of the items yeah I
I got a lady a free trip to Hawaii
because she just took all my answer so I
wonder if you can like hey you got that
because of me I work half of that right
take me with you - we were actually uh
Gary what's your Gary what's your chess
calm name
maybe we'll kind of get you in so chest
comm is weird in which you have to
challenge us when we're not in the
challenge when we're actually in the
game okay so get Gary who is Gary whose
name is giant Google oh we play you
yesterday Jim I cry a plagiarist a giant
googa is 27 to us you have read it he
wants to play do you know what no no we
already accepted your challenge and you
didn't play fool me once oh is that true
yep so it's not true we're not playing
him today
giant oh so John go Gus we accept your
challenge apparently and you decline it
was a decline where was it look at this
look at this Danny whew that was great
huh master tactics Chuck and this is a
great thing about chess that comments
you can just boom like you didn't even
see it
alright South here bad good try good try
good try I thought you were gonna do
better since you did really good against
Jessie cry yes yesterday but you're not
you're just like getting beat by Mike he
says maybe there's something to it like
he's has a engine possibly in the
background maybe I'm just better
so Gary lag Oh Gary lag that's why he
got out okay we'll see if we can similar
challenge we'll see if we can fool for
for money by accepting it look at all
look at all these moves I can promote
are you are you still playing a c5
versus everything of course of course so
when Mike when Mike plays black he's
gonna play c5 against every every first
move so if you want to have a better
chance play before white maybe you can
take advantage of it free porn
meal male alright another another
regular that's awesome alright let's see
how you do so Mike the in let's see if I
can trick this guy Oh MBA MBA regular C
season has a fish
started yeah yeah yeah thoughts on that
got off to a rough start for me if you
guys watched last week I have the Pacers
and the Ola in the Nuggets so the Pacers
got destroyed by the Pistons and the
Nuggets won right but the Nuggets got
Portland who knocked them out of the
playoffs next year last year so
oh this was not as good as I thought it
was going to uh a DTS Chandra says hey
Mike Antonia what's up how's it going
thank you for joining Gary sent it as a
challenge man maybe maybe we'll maybe a
Michael maybe this didn't work out there
this guy is master tactics today master
tactics and just pretty brutal bit huh
pretty move it
nice try nice try who was it Frank
phrase nice try nice dude less than less
than like 10 minutes your took down two
people already right and one of them
played great Jesse cry to yesterday
oh so apparently a d CH on that wants to
challenge you there the challenge me we
got nothing in the queue we got nothing
in the queue hurry up and challenge yeah
so we're waiting on people play the peep
there's the link danny Machuca
graciously put up the link so you can
click in and challenge us there is so
there is a 30-second delay between what
we say and what you see so hopefully you
can remember that and take advantage of
that gap so we are playing that's not
it's it's just it's not one of our
people it's just nobody challenged so I
have to play somebody two people
challenge man give give give giant
Google another chance well you got to be
like that keep trying to garner a chance
well may once omere once never again so
I completely understand your reasoning
for not giving people a second chance
because I don't like to give people
second chances I really agree with that
right Danny but uh Danny is lying
through his teeth he says I give you a
second chest I don't I come from a
culture where it's like you didn't get
it the first time where you
I did not give Caleb a second chance you
decided to give Caleb us a second chance
it's completely you my recommendation
was let's get rid that guy we can't
trust him
yeah I said it I first of all I back up
everything I say everything I say on
camera is how I actually feel except for
when I say like psyched and this false
you know I was being sarcastic but
normally what I say Oh giant gugus
eleven years old why don't you why don't
you kill it's a kid it's a kid I mean
yes Gary could be lying you're right
you're right but uh I mean I don't know
way I can prove it I'm just gonna get
given the benefit of the doubt I can't
no not a changed man I can't I don't
have proof the key word there is proof
bar sorrow we will try our best no
guarantee to try our best to give you a
second chance if we have a lot of people
in line then we'll probably tried those
new new people but if you are the only
one then we'll probably play you again
all right what we talked about Oh a
basketball how do you uh uh out of all
these diet dynamic duels how do you you
know how like Harden and and
what's-his-face like the horrible if not
horribly but they just broke yeah he did
not they did not do well last night not
as well as you think they were gonna do
III I was at The Price is Right
so I don't know man Gianna's pretty much
by himself took down Houston I am a cat
and I'm around 200 in human years bro
come on all right Gary you are you lovin
year so I got it man
I got it we understand we understand all
right
let's talk about now we're gonna talk
about what does this check my us bro i I
okay I trust you on you yes yes rating
weird
I am number 25 for you loving okay I
trust you we're not going to show
we're not gonna check it I trust you
mainly because I really don't want to
check it because I don't spend the time
doing it but I trust you you know who's
the state champion of Missouri right now
looky okay tell me when your state
champion okay looky
I don't first so like all these kids who
are really two pretty much by two high
rated to play in any of those classics
from tournament anymore but they play it
just to get that like I'm a state
champion on their resume no no no I'm
talking about the state of Missouri I'm
not talking about me like 1998 Missouri
scholastic state champion he's the state
champion as they like to say I think he
plan to stay open and wins I was going
oh gosh gotcha
I was I was wrong I was wrong okay
that's that's surprising who was a
hoodie like hoodie he be that's he'd be
one of our board members dog Eckhart
really Wow that's wasn't making up I
wouldn't make it's impressive that's
impressive
what is Luke now like 2100 yeah he's
getting up there yeah he's close the
national master am I gonna am I gonna
lose here they say never play up six but
whatever well mmm be vcx you are giving
Mike some trouble yeah I gotta start
paying attention start paying attention
I am thinking about moving this I'm
thinking about moving to st. Louis so I
can play in more tournaments a zen chess
all right perfect perfect come on to st.
Louis we are if you over come come if
you ever move here we're in the scent
we're in neighborhood called Central
West End pretty cool come check us out
alright alright now it's time for our
segment of top news okay so let's see so
let's see what's the top top news right
now in in the country Oh Mike did you
see the new Joker movie unfortunately
did you I
how so did you think it was that you
think was bad like that bad yes I went
into it thinking it was gonna be funny
yeah I was very disappointed so I I
didn't see it mainly because I like I
wanted the Joker movie to be more like
the traditional how you were portrayed
Joker but like this the the previews
like it was kind of a like and I don't
really care about his life kind of thing
but apparently apparently the the new
Joker movie which starts out joking
joking
Phoenix it is now become let's see
dinner done dinner done oh it is now the
number one r-rated was that true I mean
double double check this yeah Joker has
now become the number one our highest
growth highest-grossing r-rated movie
ever which is wow I didn't really think
didn't expect that and I contributed to
it I expect that in expect that it was
it was previously the record was
previously held by the movie Deadpool
starring Ryan Reynolds but now this this
past Friday that just last Friday became
second after Joker Wow Severus that's
like that's took me by surprise that's
crazy serious treatment of Joker makes
no sense that's my view that's my view
alright let's see what else is on here
okay those of you who play play the
stocks at Apple is up 1.2 3 % Hey
Citigroup I actually so so my Citigroup
stock awhile back it's now risen at one
point two percent that's pretty
impressive okay Microsoft point plus
point five that's okay interesting
Google always plus okay nice oil hasn't
changed
the euro is down whoa euros down point
one nine that's okay
Gold which is which is now and has
always been a very sure investment is
now growing 0.13% Jose Canseco called it
about three years ago all's going to
fifteen hundred it is it is now 1507 so
that's that's yeah gold is a good thing
Jose Canseco that that the yen is up
point zero five awesome awesome all
right what else is new here world Marc
Marquez Japan is up Germany is up
London's down Hong Kong's down well Hong
Kong's down because of all the stuff
that's going on but alright we won't
bring it up right Danny no that's not
what you said you for the show alright
let's see here that the Garry we'll try
we'll try okay Mike how was it horrible
just because it wasn't funny yeah yeah I
mean when you when you go to a movie
theater to see a movie for a certain
aspect and you don't get it you become
very disappointed very disappointed very
disappointed on with the news
Oh so as everybody if you guys ever
follow world news at all especially
financial news you know that US has in
the in the past year or so has placed a
lot of different taxes and tariffs on
trade trade goods right especially and
then like China and US had this thing
going on about like five about like a
financial fighting between trade trading
so it's reported now that US stocks
climbed Friday our hopes for a progress
on phase one trade deal between the
United States and China which is cool
because we want that to go we want you
that to go well but sp500 it fell short
just a reaching a new all-time high well
that's the world let's check out what's
going on in the science science
community that's always cool alright
let's make sure we don't all right Danny
Daniel wants me to anyone who wants me
to go ahead and give a shout out to the
world science festival seven o'clock
tonight okay that's he so if you want to
heat so Danny is definitely gonna check
that out now see thank you think we
don't seriously okay alright so let's
continue let's see strontium is the
first heavy element detected from a
neutron star merger dang that's a pretty
pretty cool picture like two neutron
stars merging two together basically
looks like like two Kamehameha's from
Dragon Ball Z like colliding that's
pretty cool
I like it I like it
alright
oh okay okay port so piranhas the the
carnivorous fish right there like they
chew and stuff piranhas and their plant
eating relatives to pack us so that goes
this is the plant that goes like you
know and they so dote piranhas and the
plant relative replace rows of teeth all
at once oh that's cool
so like unlike a human you know the one
teeth falls out one at a time then they
come in after the other all their teeth
all at the same time and they go like
they replace it that's interesting is
that piranhas that's piranhas and their
plant were relative to the Pacus they've
already replaced all their cheese that
will teeth at once that's cool I like it
oh this is interesting so there are
algae inside blood vessels that could
act as oxygen factories so for example
if so for like a tadpole they have two
different types of algae in their
bloodstream and they're both light
response algae so like they actually
produce oxygen in the bloodstream that's
awesome which I had that all right mmm
something about pro prozac probably
won't talk about that oh did you guys
know that light from outside the brain
can turn on nerve cells in monkey brains
how is that possible that's a long paper
I don't want to read it all right we're
just gonna break it down our Danny wants
me to break down that scientific fact
for you so we're gonna break it down all
right here we go so this happened in
Chicago the design science experiment
have in Chicago so so saying light
pulses from outside a monkey's brain can
activate nerve cells deep within the
monkey so this external control
correct so Danny just asked this is this
is the one that's where they like cut
open the skull just to check it and not
just the eye color that is correct let
me double yeah so to say because of the
experiment el LEDs in the few future
LEDs can be implanted under the people
of skulls and one day might be able to
treat treat brain disease that's pretty
awesome actually yeah that's cool that's
cool this is basic disco quote from a
doctor this is basically like scooping
out a piece of the bring and then
putting it back a few seconds later when
the risk of a C seizure has dropped says
that's what okay that's cool I like it
yes yes they had Danny asked if it was
like deep brain stimulation yes that's
exactly what it is that's awesome that's
awesome alright on to the next one so as
everybody might have guessed by by now
Danny Danny is a big science nerd
especially like tech stuff that's why
he's gonna be joining in on the what is
it the World Science Festival so he's
gonna put a link to the world sign chest
more in the chat for you guys cuz he
wants everybody to check it out
bar sorrow isn't that pronounced piraeus
no piranhas piranhas piranhas yes
piranhas piranhas yes that's correct
alright let's see what the okay here we
go
[Music]
cool so this is this might be of
interest to anybody who has Alzheimer's
we have people relate to people who has
Alzheimer's but Alzheimer's may scramble
metabolisms connection to sleep that's
interesting okay so mice with signs of
the disease signs of Alzheimer's respond
abnormally to blood sugar changes Wow
okay who we actually thought that true
ah interesting so so Danny has just
enlighten me to the fact that some
scientists and doctors call Alzheimer's
the fourth is that wears a 4/4 stage so
they call Alzheimer's a stage four of
diabetes because there's such a direct
correlation between Alzheimer's and
diabetes and now this article about the
experiment seems to collaborate that
statement let's see here wide swings and
blood sugar can mess with sleep that's
true for pretty much everybody
so foods relationship with sleep gets
even more muddled when signs of
Alzheimer disease are present Karev
makes sense makes sense okay that uh so
a dip in blood sugar caused by insulin
rejection injections also led to more
nerve cell action and more wakefulness
yep okay
that's all pretty pretty logical and um
Wow
interesting interesting I wonder who I
wonder if like a a giant corporation
where conglomerate actually like the
size of what experiments to run and
scientist is run at war if scientists
scientists themselves can decide what
they want to study and try to experiment
with it huh the scientists probably
figure out what they want to study and
then
put it like a grant proposal to them
that makes sense yeah that makes sense
like that I'm wondering if I if I'm like
to CEO I say like you know bear like you
know what I don't want to do that I want
to do this instead just like Danny asked
if I had some connections with Monsanto
I do so my my father actually used to
work for Monsanto which actually just
just recently in this past year
boudic I bought out by Bayer so I have
connections to Bay that's not Santa
anymore but my father is also a
scientist with not a lot of you know
managerial power so it's not like I have
a big connection you know just uh just
you know small he is he so he's a
biochemist I don't exactly know what he
experiments on and no idea yeah Danny
just made me fun of me and said what
kind of son are you by not nothing like
are you kidding me are you kidding me
I'm about to go go back there and just
bother you all day I'm gonna bring up
Mike my back there see if you hear you
Danny I will bring this whole chair
that's connect to the mic to you I will
rip it through the wall wait don't wait
then we have like a handheld mic you
know for the interviews yeah why don't
we use that for you plug that in [ __ ]
like that in route routed in route it in
yeah he's trying to get it routed yeah a
lot of people will you use the word
trying as to give a give somebody the
view of their actually doing something
but they're not they're not he's not
trying Danny I know you're just sitting
the chair but for pushing that button
like switching between the screens give
me that crap
you know he's playing chess right why
don't you challenge us to a game go to
chest mama challenge to the game Danny
oh okay okay all right let's see you
here then uh-oh look at this so this
this article caps be between science and
photography so so the zone icon the the
big company that produces a different
cameras of different other electronics
actually won a photography contest
because they won in there let's see
there's make sure I got this right so
one of nine Nikon's cameras took a very
small picture of a turtle embryo and at
one the nine Nikon's a small world
photography contest that's pretty cool
so it's just basically looks like the
picture basically looks like a
fluorescent turtle you know that's like
just small a small turtle you can see
you can see through everything you can
see like the blood vessels everything
that's pretty cool I like it
no wonder the day one all right well
those are those
Danny just asked me what new anime he
should watch as if I'm actually an
expert on anime I'm not he actually
watches way more anime than I I do
he watches he the the ratio of him
watching anime to me is probably like 5
to 1 like he he like he's his he will
just hit play on his plate put on his
anime play listens all day just sit
there and watch it it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous
anyways ending some new ones let's see
what's where the new ones are out there
you talk about like brand new and a lot
but not like new new seasons right ok
what am i watching currently so I'm
watching so you know the new season of
my hero academia ok
all right dan dan Ian one wants to chat
off off air about this let's see so my
hero academia that season three's out
alright I'm well I'm currently what
watching that it's pretty fun plus ultra
yes they did yet they absolutely did
yeah they up the violence on that they
did yeah for I don't want to ruin this
for anybody on the last episode like
somebody exploded that was pretty that
was interesting so for any what they
actually watches that show you you know
what the phrase plus ultra means right
that's how we're gonna play play chess
today plus ultra
I started out hot and then I drifted off
Wow Wow and I'm not doing too well this
game either
so Periyar Chess Club and Philippe area
is supposed to come down here and join
us yeah he said he was gonna come join
us for a little bit so we can talk about
stuff but maybe maybe maybe he's like
screw it I don't want to come should I
call to the front desk again call the
front desk like hey can you come alright
let me let me call let me call the front
front desk here
alright just give you guys just like
yesterday where a couple days ago oh
yeah so give you guys a little reference
here so we are in the basement this
studio is in the basement of the Chess
Club the main floor is right above us so
when you call the Chess Club the front
desk number the rule is supposed to be
there's only at most one ring before
they pick up the phone so we're gonna
test a theory real quick here we go
don't Anton call
hey Perry is Tony Chen in the bit in the
basement on on air we wanted to see if
you wanted to come come you were
actually gonna come down here and join
us
yeah come down join us cool cool
all right Perry is coming down right now
and yes it was actually so 1-1 ringing
he picked up so that's pretty awesome oh
we're done Oh Danny Danny asked me what
I think about the Nick risco promotion
so for all of you do not know Nick risco
is employee here the Chess Club he's
actually got he's actually got a couple
shows and he placed the people
occasionally he is he actually just got
a promotion
he went from a chest associate to a
senior chess associate alright so that's
pretty cool we want to give him give him
the props on that on the air good job
all right what is he here today if he's
here we should know if he's here yeah
sometimes it comes in at 4 o'clock on
Fridays ok well if he actually come
comes in before the show ends we'll have
him come come on come on the show and
say hi to everybody
sometimes he's actually on line 2 he's
actually like join the chat and
challenge us too so we'll see if that
happens and if it does we're gonna talk
to him I'll probably call him on air
then put on speakerphone so everybody I
was gonna hear all right should we
should we should we do some prank calls
why don't we call when we call like a
some higher management here to see how
they're doing and put them on
speakerphone
I actually want to see a lot some of the
top brass to come on stream just sit
like so so viewers know who they are
Tony rich was on the stream with you
yeah he was and that's like one time out
of how many years is it I want him to
more Tony rich yeah Doug
I'm sure he will so yeah so we're so
we're actually discussing one of our
board members here at the Chess Club
duck acre who was also a feed a master
his rating I think it's like 2356 last
time I checked
so we'll probably try to invite him and
see have him play I'm probably you know
chat with him as well so do you want to
invite them for that a December 8th is
it 18th for that one yeah we can
definitely buy them we can tell me if I
don't know yes so Perry's joined us we
are playing on chess calm because Jesse
cry a place on chess calm and we didn't
want to change anything well everybody
has different rules that Mike doesn't
Riki's and take challenges from whoever
I think so okay correct somebody so how
do you just just for some information
for our viewers how does how do you go
about doing that so there's a link on
our chat you click click that link for
chess calm and then it'll take you to
our profile saint-lo chess club profile
on chess table so you go to our youtube
channel right
live my color plays the people then
there's a link from there so there's a
link in the chat on our YouTube page so
there's one here somewhere there's like
two or three right right there all right
okay so you can do that or you can just
go to chess comm search st. Louis chess
club and they find us and then send a
challenge okay so it's pretty much like
Li Li chess is different yeah so just
watched well Jesse's here would be
correct
okay and different GM's have different
like like pepe only place on chess 124
so normally we play we play chess so bar
star will just said call Rex
dude heart so if I actually knew star
bar sorrow oh you knew who he is
yeah well his name we don't I don't
actually know his person but his he
challenges all the time is bat something
something bad do I need a mic you can
hear bar so if I actually knew knew
Rex's phone number I might consider it
but I probably won't do it but I might
win on time okay that's the only thing I
have going for me on the board Michael
because I have one hope and that's not
even a good hope so okay so who cares if
he even plays rook to d1 oh I got a
check even whenever you figure out it's
Chuck yeah I bet he's trying to play
with d2 so bad and you can't do it it's
like what are you doing yeah you trying
look at this Kings flashy how is that
legal Dani I think it's because you you
were doing it yeah he keeps doing that
oh we finally figured it out now I got a
really stop him here
look rook to c2 just let him check me
down oh why check then I go there let's
just hope I survive I feel like he's
definitely gonna check you Oh buddy play
back the Queen oh good good good good
yeah I'm just saying what I tell you
play no.6
yeah way I get some checks is right okay
I didn't care about that check I didn't
care I don't care there's one down one
down bar bar Soros all three bad that's
why I meant sorry I didn't really mean
you're I'm taking anything I'm sick of
this I'm sick of this increment stuff
yeah right yeah why don't why wait why
don't you get some challenges like fight
or what oh just feeeeel this is the
water okay so Mike wants to play some
bullets oh whoa no let's do it
and if I don't get challenged I've just
got challenged anybody open challenge
yeah the myth of what the comer this is
the comer defence of the Sicilian c5
july 98 just like hey you got no chance
they got no chance all right well we got
345 that means we could
you know might have six so that's
definitely a variation definitely I'm in
shock I have to do all right
Cambo challenge to you - one minute ray
- thank you well we'll play you
definitely next Cambo can you just
accept the challenge right away Danny
and then once your game gets over it
just goes directly to that game I'm not
doing that
dun-dun-dun-dun sorry I'm actually
reading articles on science is actually
really fascinating yeah eventually we'll
play it but I don't care I could go here
and that does nothing I don't know like
maybe he was afraid of well I'm not even
gonna get into this guy's head I don't
care it's like do whatever you need to
do dad well that's not the news I don't
even know
got no idea
he's sending them
now he's gonna play rook the d1 here man
I was I know a lot of our viewers are
not from the US and I was trying to give
you guys some news about what's
happening us and all the news I see it's
just like somebody getting shot somebody
getting killed like give me something
fascinating that's not like horrific
face up here yes I see it oh this is fun
look at this one all right the news hour
with Jim Lehrer give me a chessboard
give me a chessboard give the man a
chessboard my my job is like somebody's
playing chess and my job is to talk to
people and like I can't talk to people
about we need their comments are they
talking about this oh yeah let me let me
let me reread the comments right right
now it's a lot lasting I saw was about
wrecks and that's what I said about five
minutes ago they are fine what do you
got Mike what what are you guys we got
the quads tonight we're closing early
tomorrow because of the Halloween don't
even have to say what if what if they
don't do you so so they can try as many
times they want
well usually happens they come up to the
board and they try to make a legal chess
move and then they don't and then I'll
show them okay
a minute or two later then they make a
legal chess move and they get candy okay
that's what I was wondering I was like
are you that is proof that I don't give
second chances
I'm glad you I'm glad you agree with me
I'm glad you didn't you see what
happened what
so Perry just just proved the fact that
I am I don't give second chances
no no I wanted to I wanted to but Danny
said but my sister said no so I play I
play the kid did you baby be all right I
take it back then I take it back I take
everything I said take it back
what is mics over to board a rating 17
something something 56 and we already
mentioned today don't mention that I
mean what's the 39 39 years that's a
year Dave 197 New York Yankees head like
the best team elves were right like 125
ways they missed 97 obviously because
Florida beat our song Florida didn't
beat them excuse me Florida Florida won
the championship Florida beat 98 99 2000
then they lost to the Arizona
Diamondbacks 2001 so they said somebody
said please don't play rain Marant
random people you have fans watching a
show okay I didn't play random peoples
thank you very much calm down
Tom now now Perry's got faking breaking
up this baseball thing Carnales had a
great season
and they just I don't know what happened
to our championship series they just ran
into a better - yeah the way it is it
got cold it got cold in their basket 118
last 20 games there are there are times
[Music]
anybody anybody with the 100 anybody
with the one oh there's one person in
the queue
but I've already played them Oh abort
abort
how about one how about one 110 no oh
we're getting one time yeah yeah I'll
play some intentions me and Jonathan
strong nice so it's one minute plus a
ten-second incremental a delay it's like
a shot clock of 10 seconds John you guys
say that again that's correct yeah right
yeah and then you're in your time so
what's my experience Oh Mike's rating is
somewhere a little under 1,800 us yeah
like 1750 yeah
I was once over what's over 18 yeah when
I was getting lessons from Ben Feingold
the great Grandmaster so as I mean
you're Thor's uh well yeah once was
overstaying once was over one minute how
do you how do you adjust the adjust the
the scale yeah right your game with
shrimp cracking will order abort well
when I can't play with without the uh I
guess gotta abort it I didn't even as I
was playing rematch rematch I'll play a
player so when he goes be a second show
he gave me the second chair whenever one
of our viewers asked why not play some
crazy house or three checks we don't
ride come on guys come on it come on
come on
[Laughter]
solid solid hair badass play playing
once just once more well one shot pick
up one shot a day which means you can
join us next time
yeah we don't get as many challenges on
this as we did it on Lee chest yeah
that's a fact I agree I agree with that
that's true
but of course chest icon is the home of
the approach and we love the protest
what is the next season star Michael in
January and now I was we started the
show but people that have just viewing
in we have some of the best players on
the planet this year because there is no
rating cap so we have Fabiano Wesley Lee
Kwang Liam and linear Dominguez they're
all on the archbishop's can you believe
one of them yeah it's a it's a whole new
thing do you ever I mean obviously
somebody asks how do I challenge so
there's a link in this chat to the chest
comm page for us click it then hit
challenge rated games only bliss time
control or under only try so we try to
not to play any increments okay
we're trying to play 100x100 we're
trying to play one so challenge to some
bullet if you have a fast computer and
you you move pretty fast with your map
mouse bullet and we go let's do it play
someone oh do you think you're not gonna
make this not gonna make it
not gonna make this
oh is that what is that oh and I'm the
one that lost on the time oh yeah I lost
I can't get my hundred points back right
now right here no 21:59 were Sicilian
did you is that is that for real
11:41 is our reigning right now man what
I love yesterday we were at like 1800
how did you know it was on chest calm
yeah oh yeah what is this one this is
one one oh okay he thinks he's so good
see he's probably pretty good probably
pretty good you are down a long time my
friends I'll be movin I'm movin I'm
movin up really really
look straight now your pawns a little
bit it's always nice that's nice
I'll test them up again I mean does it
really that matter that much when you're
and when you're playing pull it
everything matters on the B file way
down on time
way down oh he saw that comment I'm in a
box
still in the box
he's gotta give me a big check
this pre-move a bunch on that's the way
to do it be pre moving everything who is
he gonna stop you Oh
yeah your your and you're done Oh a good
time again Queen and still it was time
to babybullet I love chess calm right
home of the protests though okay so take
take that out of the dad oh my god
that's it I win the game
boom plus 95 they're very impressed by
that man I could get the kids sure I
could get up to 2,000 beating this guy
in ten seconds huh let's do it
smoothness
alright smooth this you're in you can
find it there there's no Fred polling
interest where's where's the mystery in
its we know we just got something it's
in the closet
why not cold alright let's try it let's
try it listen let's get oh don't please
delight I just do a warm battles through
thank you Oh a just lost my quick yeah
no Perry Perry distracted me play with
his that's the only reason very
attractive with the hot Red Bull yeah
thanks for nothing Perry oh you get a
second chance if there's somebody in the
queue we don't play random people
well you gotta throw everything out
there man South hair about you killing
me I can't just let it go let it go yeah
just be like that guy just let it go
okay we just thought you were I thought
you I thought we were friends
let's let it go man
god I'm crushing this guy please say
that's checkmate
I like how I like the statement you make
I'm crushing this guy when he's way
you're down a queen right yeah okay
facts are facts I'm down a queen but I'm
pushing this guy that's a fact
come on checkmate come on come on
checkmate I thought you're gonna do the
rook to a five there and just boom
yeah he says run running around in
circles on Iran in circles there you go
there you go yeah get down a guy
involved another guy involved
oh okay Wow I did it I did it give me 45
points for that
good job yeah Mike can you give you I
miss checkmate in one but I didn't need
I didn't need it
all right who are we gonna eat still
going bullet I'm still going bowling
smooth rufus smooth this how do you that
keep all this energy of i'ma playing
bullet all zon where's the bullet
challenges
I like it that my rating is so low
because when I win I get so many points
this Manku I want to see you get to a
1500 in half an hour you got it you got
it buddy we got it there we go
I'm already up a queen I got my redbull
going I'm I'll be gonna be crushing in
the cold does our reviewers want to see
you shotgun we're not after I might have
to cuz we're not doing that in here
might be I'm just kidding we're not
doing that in here yeah too many too too
much equipment in here do that oh yeah
don't remind me about that
I actually apologized the day and never
apart
I opened a bad can right in front of his
computer whatever there was no no
problem but still I said of really
cannibal something Wow Danny allow that
huh I know I know I know I will your
arms
oh I got the rope remove the jack
I know whatever ah there for a second
yeah get get the utter work out there at
the other work I'm not gonna stalemate
them
I'll bring the other guy in here we go
yeah
okay give me some more punch 44 nice try
I'll beat anybody I'll be under mistake
that's pretty good yeah you're not gonna
you're not gonna lose a lot of games
doing that losers were G all right so I
got this guy then three four one three
four one can you blow that she's lost
her a three four one
okay all right he's only plus-one after
all that nonsense
I like how you saying three four one
asses like four for a lot I mean foot
but not enough to match the point that
value I'm caught up I plus one now I'm
plus one and I'll take double pawns if
you really want to give me double pawns
I'll take home that was pretty cool I
don't even know what I did that makes
two of us 3 it's tough to get three for
one oh yeah we I think the I want to saw
that with what Wesley so back in that
that one one time he said we took the
sacrifice the Queen for three minor
pieces I was like two years ago was this
I don't think it was a chance I think it
was a international tournament somewhere
so wasn't here no I don't think so
Gary carrier was also named as giant
cougar I believe we played you already
yeah I don't know so we can't we had to
play other people anyway we oh you just
dropped this Queen and I missed it
now we got three seconds on him getting
some point gain some time there yep just
keep on keep on doing a queen move I got
to get some spy checks here I gotta get
some split chucks going on is hanging a
lot of things cool matters okay it
doesn't matter what my mind's like
retreat challenges we only take one one
game no matter what time control is okay
oh no I'm fine fine you're fine Google
okay let's go I guess we change the
rules now Google I don't care this is
gonna give me a hundred points Wow at
least the hole so mike is declaring that
he's gonna win this before it even
begins so we got somebody saying what's
up bro watching him live South Africa
awesome I love it I love it thank you
for yeah thank you for joining us thank
you that's interesting question I'm
curious about that too serious
yeah what is what is the chassis in
South Africa meet Malawi montina yeah me
too me too
I'm crossing where's everybody drinking
Red Bull now yeah everybody in America
is that check he thought it was
checkmate but it wasn't oh I could have
just escaped
oh he's gonna do that so I think I think
sometime in the near future we're gonna
do a special show called Danny Machuca
place of people why you got it wait you
got say that Perry Perry we are trying
to force him to do this and you're just
taking his side for some reason Perry I
can't believe you're taking is I'm about
to kick you out of here you take me
aside on this you can you could join in
and be like I'm trying to her and try to
peer pressure him instead yours is like
no he doesn't do it why would you even
say that
stalemate come on still me jong-kook I
said good game as like he was taunting
you know I could just played the case
display they play now I actually spent
again apparently so Gary Gary says you
are 11 years old that's perfect because
he's mica is acting like an 11 year old
right now just gonna play you and tell
her he keep P beat you this time
pressure you wanted both a you a spur
bullet stop it it's not that good he's
only he he's only 11 years old that's
what he claims
well somebody actually looked them up on
the side and he was born in 2007 so
that's true that's true
dang I'm so close to checkmate Gary
where you from
are you from the US if so what state if
not where in the world are you from
actually playing so he's chatting and
playing at the same time
yeah he's that good he's that good he's
a little whiz kid no he's not I mean
he's typing and after you play the game
I'm asking him so in the future he can
answer us all right so this guy from
South Africa saying chess is pretty
popular this side as well but not up not
a lot of people are into it though sadly
how was that that's I feel like that's
contradictory here popular but not a lot
of people are into it yeah but doesn't
it doesn't matter
take it
one more time you are asking kids out
there oh yeah he's gonna do it
alright maybe we should play a different
opening Michael
just gonna do this over and over again
alright well Mike you have about 20
minutes to make it happen yeah 20
minutes to make this happen but in the
you know we are losing points because of
this this thing you got going on we're
losing one point a game is that we're
gonna get it a hole back we're gonna get
a hole better get it back Mike if you
don't I'm gonna be okay today be like
you remember like hey remember that day
when you lost one point at a time lost
this many points for us I know I know I
know I'm all about that oh it's right in
the family for care yeah I got him think
I got the kid thinking oh so one of our
gentlemen so what just lost my coin
chess is weird it takes special kind of
devotional that few people want to put
in to solving a constantly moving
serious repeat I love chess but I
understand why it's not popular okay all
right I guess that's a I guess that's
true even though hopefully that's
changing now nowadays yeah got my queen
back
john google good good job man you're
just like you just tearing it up against
mike tear a it up tear it up tear it up
this guy this guy's is like Queen Queen
Queen Queen I'm sorry
it was a time I'm sorry Mike yeah I mean
you just like getting crushed no dude
I'm gonna get it all back and more
alright ai-ai-ai-aight you know what I
believe you I leave you my I don't
actually I don't but I'll say I believe
you just like all just like I I say I
believe Dan Danny actually made it on a
camera one time I don't I don't buy it
Danny so Danny claims that he was on
camera once or maybe more than once but
I never seen it and I'll buy it
cuz he's he's always he strides away
from this he's like he intentionally you
know goes away from the camera and I was
like why don't you why don't you join us
Danny nobody can hear you so I don't I
don't know what why you're talking to
yourself over there why are you talking
to yourself why you're talking to
yourself
I can't hear anything you're saying all
I hear is like yeah
oh one point again that's not the point
when I beat him I'm gonna get like 500
and the more I lose the higher I'm gonna
get the more points we match requested
all right but you are depriving our
other viewers won't you try a new
opening nobody knows are you still
playing this and it looks like the same
position that opening that he just keeps
pushing that Jeep on you for watching it
I've been watching these games
okay
I'm winning I'm winning I'm winning what
I'm in check I'm winning okay I really
don't want to sometimes you just got to
do it Wow
get off my C file get off oh let's see
here what are people saying they're not
talking about that they're talking about
just attitude of people about about
chess so let's see for ourselves said I
think that what stops people from
playing is the attitude of many
mid-level players make it know who make
it seem like you have to be great at
chess to play it yeah I mean you you do
CC down a lot like they they like you
know they talk they talk a pretty good
game and then like the beginner level
players are kind of turned off by it I
see that happening all the time all the
time here we go here we go stalemate did
you win
no I'm close so close are you
look at the palm push
yeah that was close
don't play that so so so the guy you're
playing just keeps on saying good game
as of the time he is saying good game s
is like taunt on him he's like a gay
Mike I'm sure he's trying to be a
gentleman but I'm making out he's gotta
something some one our viewers are is
actually cheering you on come on Mike
all right thank you thank you thank you
that's the motivation I needed oh my god
I wonder how how many times I wonder if
Mike's gonna continue playing this guy's
the entire time there they were on the
way up about 15 minutes left Mike's you
got to do it this could be the day this
could be the day this could be the day I
hope is a day we missed his rook it was
hey sorry I got the point I wanted the
pawn let's look at that Todd that
matters in life pawn oh it was a good
move man kind of crushing this guy I'm
crushing on hook
no I got the blockade now I got the
blockade Oh Fork look at that
come on comer oh this is my time come on
move oh no I just wondered my Brooke
come on they all may come on stay on
English
stalemate stalemate stalemate stalemate
it's gotta be a stalemate how is that
not a stalemate oh I could take his
measly pawn unbelievable one move
giant Gouda good good job man good job
and this guy saying good game to you
again asset on you he's probably trying
to be nice but he's haunted in my mind
is haunted taunting to miss twins i Gary
what where were you from where you from
Gary
to miss the winds so the guy the janggu
you you're playing he was on TV twice
for something for something is it Chet
is it like chess related yeah were you
like a champ
somewhere where's that they interviewed
you well it's gonna work this is the
time no it's a sacrifice it will put up
the G pile oh look at that now I got it
forever I got some stuff going man
equates to like how it's like it doesn't
matter if you're down on time even
though you lost on time oh he has a good
shot here then I got my point back I
can't wait to see how you react when
when like we have a mouth we have like I
was my bishop come on
I'm really curious oh how is he gonna
react if heat there was a mouth there's
like a mouse slip and he was like no
there's like throw something on the
ground I wanna see I wanna see that
so viewers are any of you guys gonna be
insane st. Louis in the next couple of
weeks
come see us we have some big tournaments
coming up join us Thanksgiving opens and
automata Thanksgiving satellites next
weekend playing what
oh so Jani Dan did Danny just said he
heard that I was playing in the
Thanksgiving open which I actually did
tell him that to his face I was gonna
play like chili rocks
yeah yes bunch of [ __ ] players so
unconditionally I I will probably play
not not all all all the rounds I'll
probably play like two or three rounds
yeah I can't do it I can't spend all
that time I have stuff to do man yeah I
know I'm trying to get I haven't played
yeah I've been play tournament chess in
a long time so I'm trying to get back
into all right so the guy you're playing
the kid you're playing is from New
Jersey he was on shark shark tank and
Jimmy Fallon wow that's impressive
was this his so was this chest yeah was
this chest related
Danny Danny is straight-up calling you a
liar in the back you can't hear him
history of calling you Gary look
lijinsky yeah so when you when you so
like on those shows were you talking
about chess or is this like a shark a
shark tank that's what I'm kick here is
a wood with business venture you were
trying to love it as an 11 year old I
want to see I want to hear hear about
that I'm also gonna Google you right now
to see what yeah oh somebody say Mike
Hummer is playing an engine is that true
and now we're thinking we got to the
bottom of it we got to the bottom
this okay this is the kid this is the
kid yeah dan so Danny in the back and
say maybe you're real like he's still
thinking you're not great he's so that's
kids lying to me
yes I won by checkmate 95 points mean
that's mean oh my god yeah I beat the
engine he is 11 beat of nine straight
times
hey seven times so so so this kid I
don't is this true you invented a
wearable device for allergies holy crap
man I'll give you if that's true I'll
give you a hand for that one that's
pretty impressive
yeah so that's where you're pitching on
Shark Tank that's that's cool that's
cool
I see a picture you with a giant five
thousand dollar check in the background
I want that I'm actually very I'm
looking at your stuff right now and I'm
very impressed I'm very impressed
but since you're only 11 if your ratings
actually like in the 2000 almost 100
maybe well you can yours just that org
look them up yeah I will about if why
don't you come down to say no sometimes
when I want a big tournaments maybe I
will invite you to uh yeah yeah maybe
you get good enough maybe you can play
one of our I am GM norm tournaments you
know all right we have one more game
left one game left it's 424 so it's true
so as she said he appeared on two shows
including tonight's show and
where he shared his combination your
nose in earmuffs
and then in Rachael Ray Show where he
pitched out a watch for allergies
investors from ABC's Shark Tank Wow I
mean breast man
I mean breasts yes yes yes no he has too
far away you said what a sore loser to
you because you won't accept you got it
you got it backwards I'm a sore winner
okay one out of how many time with 1 out
of 15 how do you Michael Gary for the
record we're very impressed we we invite
you to come come to st. Louis sometime
come hang out with us maybe you can be
on our show all right Oh 1,700 ok you
play some crazy opening all right and
Danny Danny is now officially impressed
with you to Gary he was he was doubting
you further basically the entire show
now he's coming around to it all right
got to help me out tone all right Newars
you have we have four minutes left so
this probably is a lot last game all
right Cass is this Kasparov Oh Cass saw
her off okay I thought it was scary
Casper oh holy crap okay play right here
tanks she'll be all right
you'd be fine he's just 1700 so Gary we
see your challenge however we're out of
time so this is the game
Perry's playing is probably gonna be the
last time okay and yeah great if you
come to sunny st. Louis visit us my name
is Tony you can pretty much know
everybody else on the show well show you
it will show you around all right
actually if you can come to the
Thanksgiving open November 29th to
December 1st I'll be pretty cool too
playing on big tournaments you know
Danny is saying maybe you and I will
play probably however if I see you I
might just come I just was draw no I
can't cuz I can't I'm not gonna I'm like
Kobe Bryant I'm like Kobe Bryant
majority of time I don't I don't play
play games that I know I can't win so
crazy
you know I Kobe Bryant once said like he
won't he won't do a dunk contest against
who is against Vince Carter because he
knows he's not gonna win so you can
cookie like I wanted competing things I
know I'm gonna win
No you afraid to check me already
well he's got this going on but his his
wait troops y squared Bishop is gone how
we doing on time I came time to look at
it
we're down like a minute okay see see
see five boom done yeah no see five
could take I could win this pawn their
roots there no I got my queen backing it
up oh that's right
c5 man c5 all right Danny's back backing
my CC 5mu even though that's like
probably the first time in my life they
says he's actually agree with me like he
this did he disagrees me for fun like if
sometimes I'll say like 1+1 he goes to
you like no no was he gonna play here
boom boom
well you're down on time you got oh
that's not good yeah what if I just
played take take the note oh yeah
take follow the Queen Kegel tonight
well then you'd gain 90 pin all right
take what the night manage what I said
Danny's Danny's Khan contradicting me
again what is that about
oh so you should have taken what - oh
man
cccc waste your parents see what happens
pretty good
whatevs Bishop d6 by whose blood bishop
sure bishop sure are you gonna move on
night night night night to d3 is that
the plan if you maybe maybe
Danny asked if I was so provisional I am
not I actually uh yeah so I so I so
another employee here named Isaac he's
usually in the back room with Danny he's
not here today he and I actually played
a lot of classical games just so I can
get out of there
professional really yeah yeah I was like
I think it was like two years ago when
we play like ten classical games in a
row just because we needed to 1980 games
to give us a free reading B so we play
ten I Isaac and I played ten games I
from I remember correctly I won nine
drew one I crushed Isaac crushed Isaac
for rush nice get out of here you can be
hearing defendants of all you want he
knows it's true it's a it's a rate it's
rated game so you can look at him on you
see you crushed Isaac that's pretty
impressive
yeah I don't think that's true I would
talk about like rating or skill skill
level I didn't I'm sure I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure that's falls on on both
fronts
Danny's made making a/c seem like I'm
just trash talking against Isaac because
he's not here but like I mean yeah to a
certain degree that's true I Isaac and I
like to banter back I can't believe you
meet Isaac that much ya know no offense
no offense Perry he likes to
underestimate me because I don't play
him on purpose and he's like oh you're
scared of me my god
that's fine you can think for two years
that's why you to think that way Perry
you know boys and girls up here isn't
Grace out there even all everybody
ladies and gentlemen let me tell you
something about this world in this world
what about the greatest advantage you
can have is to be underestimated
alright that's a great advantage you're
gonna have you think that's a great yeah
it's seed and Danny agrees with me so
you can underestimate yeah so we have
we're almost done with the show I just
want to point out we have a special
guest coming in right now it's Abby
I'm trying Danny I'm trying my best to
get to get some girls on the show but I
can't
they are you say no oh here she comes
again Abby hey we have a chair for you a
chair for you somebody asked where is
Jonathan so Jonathan I believe is
actually sitting upstairs in the main
floor doing some work
Oh Jonathan left yeah he was like screw
this I'm leaving home we don't have a
family to take care these are fine so we
have a question why aren't you guys
playing Onley chess it's much easier to
send challenges so you probably joined
this pretty recently because we actually
talked about this many times we are so
we have grandmaster she Jesse Crichton
ret residence right now he only plays on
chess calm and even though he's not on
the show today we decided to stick with
it because we really want didn't want to
change anything
because
that's pretty good so Dan so Danny just
informed me that he looked up or my
games against Isaac so he said we play
13 games which I don't remember playing
13 but we played 13 games and I won 10
and drew won't drew one so it's so it's
what I said was true pleasure watching
your stream gents it's been cool thank
you very much my man thank you very much
good game hope you join us later too
whenever you guys stream we are
streaming so we stream Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday and then when is the GM
stream - Tuesdays at 12:00
usually at 12:00 p.m. with Jonathan
Wednesday and Thursdays with the GM at
3:00 p.m. and then Fridays Fridays with
Mike yep is the Friday night action
quads are super fun come on down it's
only ten bucks get to play three uh
three rounds twenty minutes with the
five-second delay for ten bucks and you
can win 36 bucks
yep and don't thinking about the
Thanksgiving open and yeah please follow
us on all social media Facebook Twitter
we usually have messages to tell you
guys when we play and when we stream so
that's another way you can keep up with
everybody come into a room so all right
we have we have to go we're out of the
show so thank you for joining us tonight
join us again next Tuesday
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you